In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 11th, on which we commemorate the synaxes of
the Mother of God in memory of the hymn Axionestine by the Archangel Gabriel.
Some distance from Carias, the capital of Mount Athos, in the direction of the monastery
of Panto Crator, there lived a virtuous Hyromonc with his young disciple.
One Saturday evening, the elder went to take part in the vigil, celebrated as it was every
week in the church of the Protathon, leaving his disciple alone.
When evening came, an unknown monk knocked at the door, and the disciple took him in for
the night.
They met at dawn to sing the office of matins in the chapel, but when they got to the
ninth ode, while the disciple was intoning the hymn more honorable than the cherubim,
before the icon of the Mother of God, the stranger prefaced it with the following words.
It is very meat to bless thee, who didst bring forth God, ever blessed, and most pure,
and the Mother of our God.
When prized at hearing this verse for the first time, the disciple asked his guest to write
it down, and when he could find no paper, the monk engraved the hymn deeply and easily
on a stone tablet.
He added, from this day onwards, all the orthodox will sing the hymn to the Mother of God
like this, and he disappeared.
The elder, hearing on his return an account of this apparition, understood that the strange
monk was none other than the archangel Gabriel, and went to recount the miracle to the Protos
of the Holy Mountain and the elders.
They sent the tablet to the patriarch and the emperor, for they him to be made known throughout
the Orthodox world, and moved the icon before which the miracle had taken place into the
church of the Protaton, where it has stood ever since behind the altar, as the sovereign
abyss and protectors of the Holy Mountain.
This icon of the Axion Estine, it is very meat, is, together with the Portaitisa, the most
celebrated of the miraculous icons of the Garden of the Mother of God.
It has only been taken out three times to be venerated by the people.
In 1963, 1985, and 1987, and at these times received the honor due to a head of state.
Every Easter Monday it is taken in solemn procession, round caries, and the surrounding area to
bless the countryside and protect the inhabitants from all harm, through the prayers of our Holy
Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us, and save us.